DON DODGE: Hi.
I'm Don Dodge, and this
is Google Root Access.
Today my guest is
Jay Simons, president
of Atlassian Software.
Welcome, Jay.
JAY SIMONS: Yeah.
Thanks, Don.
DON DODGE: Jay, developers
know what that Atlassian is,
but maybe some of
our audience doesn't.
What is Atlassian?
What kinds of products?
What do you do?
JAY SIMONS: Atlassian is an
enterprise software company.
We make collaboration
software used
by software teams
and other companies
to help them build
software better.
So whether you're an
automotive company building
the next electric car or you're
an investment bank building
a new trading algorithm or
you're a shoe company building
digital devices to track
fitness, all of those things
involve software.
And software is an
important key ingredient
to how products, markets,
industries, the world
will innovate.
DON DODGE: JIRA is a
product that I know about,
but there are others.
What is JIRA?
And what do your
other products do?
JAY SIMONS: Think about
our product portfolio
as kind of the
three-legged stool.
Any team that's
building software
needs to do three things.
They need to track projects
and activity and work.
That's what JIRA does.
They need to kind
of share and iterate
on unstructured content ideas,
specifications, roadmaps,
product requirements, the
things that actually define
what you're going
to build and what
that work is going
to be involved in.
And Confluence is the
product that handles that.
And then, because we're
talking about software,
developers need to share and
iterate and collaborate on code
and do a number of different
things around that code,
things like code reviews or code
insight, continuous integration
and deployment.
That kind of product
family is anchored
by a product called Stash,
which is a management
application for the distributed
source control system Git.
DON DODGE: Great.
So developers, then,
are your users.
JAY SIMONS: Developers are a
very important group of users.
But actually, if you think
about the modern software team,
the developer is actually
a very important minority.
The group of people that
are building software
include project managers,
key stakeholders
that are going to define
what developers need
to build to begin with, people
in support and marketing,
documentation
writers, designers.
There's a whole
bevy of people that
are involved in actually
designing, specifying, building
supporting software.
And so our products help
bring all of those people
together, technical and
non-technical alike.
DON DODGE: And how are your
Atlassian products sold?
JAY SIMONS: Our products
are sold over the web.
We use the internet,
basically, to reach customers.
They're available to
customers to deploy
both in the cloud as a
service or to install and run
on their own servers
behind the firewall.
DON DODGE: And is it a
subscription-based things
or license?
Or how does it work?
JAY SIMONS: The licensing
model for the cloud deployment
is subscription, either
monthly or annual,
which is fairly typical.
The deployment model
behind the firewall
is sold as a perpetual license
with an annual maintenance
and support agreement.
DON DODGE: You compete with some
open source kinds of products
or free freemium
kinds of products.
But you're an enterprise
software company.
So how does that work?
JAY SIMONS: Well,
I would say we're
an alternative to both open
source at the bottom end,
or at one end,
and very expensive
traditional enterprise
software from IBM and Microsoft
and HP at the top end, so
things like Rational or even
Team Foundation Server
or HP Quality Center
at the very, very top end.
Those are products that
are millions and millions
of dollars a year that typically
are sold on a per developer
seat basis.
Then at the other end, you've
got open source products
like Bugzilla and Trac
and Mantis and Redmine.
And then there's a
bevy of companies
in the middle that
do various things.
I think Atlassian
is, I think, actually
the only company that's combined
just excellence in discipline,
initial project
tracking, content
collaboration, and
source collaboration.
And that's what sets
us apart, one thing.
The other thing is that
we've intentionally
priced, in part because
of our business model,
to be affordable and
provide great value.
And in exchange for providing
that great value to customers,
we don't have the traditional
expensive enterprise sales
organization to justify or
support the expense of products
at that other end.
DON DODGE: So you compete
at both ends of the market,
and you've priced it so that
you can compete effectively
with the free or
freemium-type models.
But then you compete with
big software companies.
Those big software
companies typically
have technical
support and pre-sales
and all kinds of consulting
and all that sort of thing.
So I understand how you can
compete at the open source
level or freemium
by pricing well,
but how do you compete
at the high end
against these big companies?
JAY SIMONS: By building
better products.
By investing in R&D.
Where those companies have
to invest in all the
things you'd mentioned,
sales and more
support and pre-sales,
to help explain how their
products should work or help
compensate for maybe where the
product doesn't work like it
is, we invest a very
significant amount in R&D
to make sure that the
product kind of sells itself.
We believe that we sell
largely to a technical audience
and a technical
constituent who, I think,
believes inherently that
they have the capacity
to understand whether this
product will support what they
need or what their team needs.
And we invest a
lot in making sure
that the product does that.
So they can spin it
up online, or they
can download and install it.
And ultimately, it's going to
say, hey, welcome, evaluator.
Let's show you around and help
you understand whether or not
this is going to do the job.
DON DODGE: Developers and
product managers and project
managers are the
same kinds of people
and do the same kinds
of job, whether they're
in a tiny startup up or
in a Fortune 500 company.
So I guess, in some sense,
supporting them, it's the same.
You're supporting
the users, and you
don't do anything
different for Fortune 500
developers versus small
startup developers.
JAY SIMONS: We don't.
Very, very large companies have
different scale and performance
requirements.
And so there is a difference
between a company that
has 100 people using our
software in a company that
has 10,000 or 20,000.
We built a product to support
both ends of that spectrum,
which was hard, requires a
lot of R&D and specialization
and people that understand
how to make it scale.
And you have to think where
sometimes if you build
a software with only 10 users,
the user picker that you design
is different than
the one for 10,000.
I think we're a
unique company that
needs to think about
solving problems
for a very large and
varied customer base.
When you're supporting teams
of 10 and teams of 10,000,
designing a product
that supports
both ends of the
spectrum is, I think,
a difficult R&D
challenging and one
I think we do well, probably
better than any other software
company I can think of.
DON DODGE: And do you
handle developer support
through discussion
forums and FAQs?
How do you do that?
JAY SIMONS: Big emphasis
on documentation.
Again, our whole philosophy
is around customer empowerment
and customer self-service.
We believe in
that, and we invest
a lot to make that-- That
doesn't happen organically.
You have to consciously
invest in making sure
that that works by
building great product,
by building great
documentation, by thinking
about empowering your end
user or your customer.
We do have a technical
support organization.
We also complement that with
community-based support.
And so again, we invest a lot in
creating an opportunity for it.
We've got 30,000 companies
as active companies using
our software and, in that
group of active companies,
millions of end users.
So there's a treasure
trove of people
who actually know how to solve
problems, either for themselves
and might be willing
to share that solution
with other customers.
Creating an
opportunity, I think,
for customers to help each
other is a really important part
of a scalable support model.
And we complement that with
our own technical support
organization to dig
deep where we're needed.
DON DODGE: Wow.
Awesome.
Well, thank you very much.
This is an interesting
topic, and I'd
like to have you back to
discuss this more in the future.
But this is all we
have time for today.
So thank you for joining us.
I'd like to remind you that
if you're a cloud developer,
we have a special $2,000
credit for Google Cloud.
You can see the details
of where to sign up
for that credit
on the screen now.
Thank you very much, and
we'll see you next time.